und die pandemie in der tat richtig dass
bei einem noch nicht gebracht und das
gegen hatten sie heute abend in eine
situation kommen wollen jetzt noch war
ausgehen bevor im kreativ die stadt
wieder zum stillstand kommen und da
hatten möglicherweise auch dazu bei
gesagt dass die dass der angreifer
gesagt haben wir machen das jetzt denn
in zwei drei tagen gibt es keine
ordentlichen also das kann ich mir gut
vorstellen dass das eine kalkulation war
dass das mit ein auslöser und ein
beweggrund sogar diesen anschlag heute
zu machen und nicht später
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren